(opera singing)
- Music is one of those things
that just reaches people,
and I feel like opera specifically
has that effect on everyone.
It's pure, it's raw, and it's beautiful.
I do feel like we're making
it so everyone can enjoy it.
(applause)
(orchestral music)
My name is Alexis Cregger,
and I'm an opera singer
and a member of the Opera Collective.
We're about 30 right now.
We come together two to three times a week
to bring opera to the people.
(opera singing)
We sing in the subways of New York City.
My mom used to always listen
to the Met broadcasts.
When I was 14, she took me to
the Met for the first time
and Queen of the Night came on stage
and I saw her, and I said,
"That's what I wanna do."
(opera singing)
Most people do have that
initial feeling of oh, opera.
I don't like opera.
What is this opera?
But bringing opera to the subway
really makes it for everyone
and it really makes it
something that people feel like
they can connect with.
It's one of those places where
people just go by every day
(applause)
all day long, and so you really get to see
all walks of people.
(cheering)
(piano music)
We've had people come and stand or sit
for practically the
entire time we're there.
We had a note that was given to us
by a girl who was really not
doing that well that day.
She was sitting on one of the benches
and she was there for
probably close to two hours.
At the end of it, she came up
and put this note along with
some change into the bucket.
Basically she had said
that she had been contemplating suicide
and listening to us, sitting
there and hearing that music
it just, it changed her mind.
That's why we do this.
(applause)
I'm so happy that we can
make that sort of impact.
It's a really beautiful thing.